so why are we working on automated
driving not necessary why everybody's
working on automated driving but why we
at sir I are working on Smitty driving
is that number that insane number of one
point 35 million road traffic deaths per
year right it's not Robo taxi that's
gonna bring this number down it's not
normal driver assistance system that's
gonna bring that number down because if
you didn't have your driver assistance
system that number would be three times
as high it's something else so that's
why we have research in our middle name
is we need to that's a hard problem
if it was easy would be criminal for
humanity to not have solved it by them
so how are we gonna solve that problem
well really what is missing right we're
we're not idiots and especially you are
the the generation of future non idiots
that are gonna have to solve this
problem and and really there's something
missing there right and if you look
today and I just took you know like you
all in the in the middle of the action
so you've seen a lot of other autonomous
cars
this is like the Alexis's and the
Toyotas you can buy today or very soon
and this is like the ones that are
prototype level four level five
self-driving cars that you might have
seen around already before on the right
and there's something besides they all
look cool now right no KFC bucket on the
top you know we had those before what
what's the difference right and one
little difference is that these have
nothing on top right what's in there is
all lied arts very expensive very fancy
lied ours right and so most of the
people that are serious about level four
level five and doing it right in a safe
way to decrease death they use lighters
all right we had for a little bit of
black panther on our cars didn't work
out too well so we have to do something
else so can we get robust 3d perception
from vision right so all these cars that
you know right they they today's cars
they use vision they use radar these GPS
they don't use lidar not at least the
lidar that you would see in the
self-driving prototypes today right so
the key question the key thing that's
missing really to make this connection
between the most advanced level for
prototypes you see today and today's
cars
is I think I believe this question is
one big part of what we're doing at our
I can we get robust 3d perception front
vision so I'll cover a little bit why
self supervised pseudo lidar is the main
research direction we're focusing on to
actually address that question a couple
of recent papers that we've made on that
topic and and then I'll wrap up with a
conclusion so who has heard about pseudo
lidar a little show of hands or very few
people monocular depth estimation
alright okay so you're it's the same
thing it's just one is trendy because
Elon Musk accelerates address so so
pseudo lidar and molecular defamation is
basically the same thing I mean it's
almost it's the same thing because it's
just like once you have a per pixel
depth and you know your camera in turn
six guess what you have a point cloud
right so we what we want to do in this
problem is take a single RGB image right
and feed it through a mono def deep
network a convolutional network and
produce per pixel depth right it's like
turning the camera into a range sensor Y
T RI and and Toyota we believe we can
solve that problem and tackle that
problem well it's one thing it's because
of the data right so two ties number one
car manufacturer in the world we have
hundred million cars on the road today
we sell 10 million new cars every year
and you know if you look at like very
you know like simple statistics we have
basically the largest dashcam in the
world right you can see it this way and
and this is like tens of petabytes of
data per day which is like an order of
magnitude of YouTube this is not the
reality today right just like we're not
getting tens of petabytes today right
your data is safe where it is in your
Toyota's but weird we're working on
algorithms and and they're big plans
that are being set in motion to use as
much data as we need eventually to solve
that problem right so this is the
challenge right what do you do with that
by the way this this little bubble here
is YouTube so the challenges that we
have to deal is like is like dwarfing
YouTube scale so in terms of scale and
the magnitude of the challenges we have
to face
this is a big challenge but it's also a
big opportunity right and this is there
are many many many papers you know it's
like big data deep learning all the hype
etc right so there's always like a
little kernel of truth in the hype and
there's plenty of research evidence by
the way including 2011 so like one year
before the whole imaginet revolution
we've random for us right there is
machine learning has a long history of
being better with data right so this is
not just a hype and so one thing that's
been clear now with the experimental
evidence we've been acquiring at the
recent years is that if you compare
performance with amount of data you
improve with with data older algorithms
including those from my PhD today
plateau fairly quickly right and the
reason is because you have a modular
system you handcraft features those
features are not learned etc deep
learning learns everything so it scales
better there's a little caveat to this
which is it scales with labeled data
right that's where the hype stops right
where all these people that you here
because they have so much raw data
they're gonna win the race to whatever
race they want to win definitely not the
race to zero fatalities it's with
labeled data right and labeled data
right now it means you look at it you
have people to look at it right and one
of the challenges is that even if Toyota
was enslaving all of humanity's to click
on pixels for us we can't label it like
it's just not possible right so so we
have to invent some some new ideas right
and and and do research on that problem
and and that's where we're working on
self supervised learning so it's not
just a dream of unsupervised learning
you know the young the initial dream
right which now here abanda self
supervised learning which was we learned
just from raw data you know I have five
year old daughter I don't let her watch
YouTube every day and then I hope she
gets into Stanford it's it's you know
there's structure in the data right it's
why it's just not unlabeled raw data
like cat videos right and so how do we
leverage that structure is key so really
the question is we have a lot of data
but we don't have supervision what do we
do right so runaway
so I tell you at a scale again like you
know like there's no free lunch theorem
is and everything so you can't like be
very generic so I'm gonna be specific in
my statements so self supervised
learning for computer vision we want
exploiting large volumes of unlabeled
but structured camera data
okay so unlabeled is bad structured is
good training we want to only require
unlabeled driving video data because
that's by vast majority the amount of
bits we have and then wipe so a lot are
in particular right again we're focusing
and lidar is in very few cars so you
have some cars that have lidar that you
can commercially by or very soon but
it's typically like range sensors like
you have probably all in your robots you
know like your one lidar except here we
have four it's really just like not not
good for driving it's just collision
avoidance and so we use luminaires which
I don't know if you know is the startup
that does like very very advanced light
ours with like a crazy range of like 250
meters because they operate in a 1550
nanometer range wavelength so that's the
cars like that see if you see like the
rooftops like the of our cars of our
prototypes around the valley you will
see like no KFC bucket that's because we
have these very expensive lighters in in
that in there you don't want to have a
Camry with that the price is not
something I think even VCS would be ok
with so cameras Arabic kutis they
provide rich semantic and geometric
sensing and really like so all the
Toyotas now that you can buy they all
have cameras radars and like a fairly
advanced cameras and and you know with a
be with all these advanced safety
features so it's really like in tens of
millions of cars now what about stereo
well we'll leave that for the pizza
discussion so supervised learning I
assume you all know about supervised
learning but it's very simple is you get
the data feed into a model make
predictions pay a loss by comparing two
labels given to you by an Oracle
typically a human raw data easy to
acquire target data expensive difficult
to acquire so supervised learning is
just looking at saying
I don't like easy expensive hard
expensive things just remove them so
here
the magic trick right it's like you know
you have to incorporate prior knowledge
right that's that's the thing you have
to do to pay off instead of labels so at
across this year we made a paper called
super depth which was our first
contribution really on this direction of
molecular definite works or absolute
lidar
and so here the idea is the following is
a training time we will assume we have
stereo data right so again we're
learning a molecular networks which that
that inference timing can work on the
raw monocular video stream but that
training time let's assume for the
moment that we have a stereo camera so
we have a left and right image from the
parallel we know the baseline we feed
the left image into the monocular deaf
Network we get a depth map right so yeah
that for inverse depth per pixel then
geometry tells you actually if you know
the baseline and you know the depth you
can actually know the mapping of pixels
from one frame to the other so what you
can do is you can warp right so this is
this view thins the synthesis you can
warp one frame on to the other and then
you can see whether after warping the
pixels have the same color right if
you're if you warp correctly this pixel
should line their college should be the
same and so that's called the
photometric loss and that's basically at
the heart of all the self supervised
geometric methods you would see there
and so the lost again so it's like if
those of you that are already familiar
with deep learning you know you minimize
the loss over pixels and here you
minimize the loss between the image and
the target image and the Warped target
image and the loss is decomposed in
multiple terms and the beauty of these
is that really this is the supervision
right this IT hat right this is not a
human provided label this is a geometry
provided label right and so this Lost's
this photometric law that I mentioned
before it basically you can pay it off
the raw data directly then of course we
add some additional terms to make it
better because there are some
photometric ambiguities like a white
wall you know all the pixels on what
wall look white so they're invalid
there's a plenty
invalid matching that yield the same
zero loss so we have to add additional
regularization terms and so that
basically was like kind of like
kick-started this kind of idea of you
can do that learn to predict that from a
single image by not requiring any
supervision and that started basically
circa 2016 of come on Godard and and all
those folks one of the things we found
was when you do driving you want to see
far ahead right because when you go fast
you want to anticipate in advance so you
need to see far ahead so seeing far
ahead with cameras mean operating at a
high resolution so you have as many
pixels and as possible on objects far
ahead so when we tried these ideas
initially to see if they would actually
work beyond the research paper we tried
them directly on our high resolution
cameras and what we found is that
results were actually significantly
better than the research report so I
don't know how often it happens to you
when you try to reproduce a paper and
you got better results never happened to
me you know always the other way around
if I get any number at all
and so here we were really wondering
what the what's going on you know did we
train on the test set you know like this
usual stuff and and actually didn't
after investigating a bit more what we
found and we could reproduce was well it
makes sense
resolution matters because again we're
warping a frame onto another and then
we're comparing the pixels and I
mentioned this white wall effect if you
look at the white wall from afar
everything looks white so any wrong
matching yield zero loss you're not back
propagating you don't learn but if you
look really close you would see there
are some smudges there are some details
that will actually yield a little bit of
a loss right that would resolve some
photometric ambiguities so operating at
a higher resolution means you're not a
liasing out you're not blurring the tiny
details that help recover and so roads
they might look very uniform on the
downsample resolution but at a high
resolution you would see these
irregularities that enable you to learn
a proper matching and so we said okay
naturally well can we go beyond you know
and actually do super resolution this
time and so that's what we did we took a
standard network like the distant
architecture which is a unit
architecture with like you have
convolutional layers d convolutional
layers skip connections and we added sub
pixel convolution blocks which are
typical operations that are there to try
to have this
details when you learn super-resolution
networks right again these details are
lost right it says thank you compressed
the signal you lost those so what you're
trying to do is you're trying to learn
weights that from data captured patterns
that says oh I've seen these kind of
things it typically actually corresponds
to a high-resolution signal like this so
we use that we I'm gonna go quickly over
those results because we have newer
results but we improve the state of the
art qualitatively quantitatively one
thing that's really kind of you should
ask as robot assists when people talk
about that especially computer vision
people like me that are not robot
assists you should say show me a point
cloud right I don't believe you that I
don't know what it is this is probably
unscaled this is in this case it's very
it's not and scale but look at a point
cloud right and so very few papers
actually are not like are showing point
clouds because their point clouds suck
so I encourage you to look at more
details we have the video on YouTube you
can have a look at this I wouldn't drive
off of this point cloud all right or the
collision avoidance off of this point
cloud but it's starting to look like
it's going somewhere so we said okay
let's go further
actually you know let's take a step back
what if we don't have stereo training
time what if we have just videos because
remember we assume we know the baseline
is frontal parallel taken at the same
time so the world is static right and so
you're warping one frame onto another we
were very simple geometric relationship
now videos right structure for motion
slam etc take a frame you move the world
changes you take another frame that's
the signal we have how what geometric
prior do we use in our loss for self
supervision CSS is the Toyota safety
sense right that's that's the that's
today's cars right that's the data we
get today and that's the data we have to
train that scale from so that's what we
did recently we extended this work super
def into a new work
it's called pack net sfm it's available
in archive currently under review and
and so here the idea was the following
is remember we had the stereo so left
image right image now we have instead a
pair of frames which is human
but we can pretend it's a generalized
stereo pair let's pretend and let's do
the same approach right so one of the
difficulties there is you don't know the
six degrees transformation six degrees
of freedom transformation from the
camera right it can move in 3d space so
how do you warp and then what do you do
about the dynamic objects right so
here's the architecture that we have by
the way like this is called structure
for motion in computer vision this
problem and here you have let's say
target image so typically you when you
train you train on the image at T and
then you have like context images like t
minus 1 and t plus 1 and so here we feed
the target image through pack net our
new neural network architecture that we
proposed specifically for that task
generate a depth image and then we also
have to have a pose network which is a
deep network that takes series of frames
and tries to estimate the the
transformation the ego motion of the
camera basically between frames
progresses or rotation and a translation
right and then you can do the view
synthesis right you know the depth you
know the images you know the
transformation you can work you can
apply the same principle of view
synthesis assuming the world is static
which means assuming that the dynamic
objects are noise create noise in your
warp so invalidate your warp but in a
minority of pixels that's the underlying
hypothesis that the system is doing when
it's learning okay in addition to that
we added if you you know most robots and
cars definitely know at what speed
they're going they don't know precisely
how the camera is moving in 3d space but
they know they have an auto meter they
know like a wheel encoder or whatever
they know at which speed they're going
right so if you know that you can
actually add some constraints to your
translation vector the magnitude of your
translation vector and one thing that's
really interesting is that all that it's
like in the structure from motion from
you have a scale ambiguity meaning that
I could like we could all be like tiny
midgets and that room would be tiny room
and it would yield the same laws the
same everything
so there's scale and big ete you
typically have to resolve it with some
measure of sky
at test time right so when you deploy
your model you need to do something that
tells you how you should scale your def
your your everything to metric space
here with this approach if you train
with the velocity supervision and you
can train a translation magnitude to be
in line with your velocity this is
scaled so this is forcing the output of
the network to be scaled also and the
solar our whole approach is scaled and
metrically accurate so at test time you
don't need to know a notion of scale the
network has internalized
a notion of scale so here is an example
video I I won't play it in its entirety
but you will you can find it again
online I'll directly skip to the cool
part which is the point clouds if it
works so you have the range image right
so the visualization that all the people
in computer vision know and love and
so that's the points out so here what
you're seeing at the top so this is the
image it gets fed to our network our
network outputs scales depth right and
also it outputs the post right the Delta
of the post of the camera so we can
actually do denser construction so what
you're seeing is the point cloud colored
by the pixels right that you get from
from our network this is the height map
so I encourage you all again to look at
this online the video is on YouTube
because like crappy codecs so look at it
in details and what you'll see is we can
even see difference in the height for
the curb so operating at a very high
resolution our network also is able to
have like a very fine-grained notion of
depth and of 3d scene geometry dense 3d
scene geometry one of the other cool
things you could see in this video is
that garbage cans you know one of the
cool things about unsupervised learning
and self surprise learning is if you
didn't think that you should model
garbage cans in your object detector et
cetera and suddenly there's a garbage
can on the road and you're like oops
there's I don't know what it is with
unsupervised learning if you've seen
garbage cans enough right you actually
can just like a lidar detect it right
and so here what you would see in these
videos you would see that very often
we have actually a very correct depth on
on weird categories that actually our
objective detection team has never
thought of actually modeling which is
the entire point of unsupervised
learning is going beyond what an
engineer or a machine learning engineer
you know we think I need to model that
in the world so just a little bit of the
secret sauce in details because I think
one of the key contributions in that
paper was really the architecture
there's a cool paper by Google brain
looks buyer and and co-authors
where they show something that's like
you know in hindsight obvious but it was
not obvious until this paper which is
self supervised tasks right which which
notion of self supervision which
geometric property or prior you're using
right have an affinity with the network
architecture so one of the very hard
things about deep learning is how do you
design this network architecture do I
put 10 layers 15 layers 30 layers how
many like do I put 64 channels for that
layer do I do is keep connection there I
mean
there's a neural architecture search
that's going on but no architecture
search right now is like like I did peak
hype it's just like if I already have a
good Network please give me one more
percent by fiddling a little bit with
the parameters around right that's how
it works but here what what we found is
that we use again our prior in designing
the network and one of the things that
was important was no down sampling so if
you remember the unit architecture I
showed you before is like we take the
full image we like convolution down
sampling convolution down sampling
evolution down sampling up sampling
convolution of sampling convolution
right and we say resolution is very
important then why are we going through
the effort of destroying all that
research and information and trying to
reinvent it right and the reason is
technical debt the reason is because
these networks were designed for images
right the encoder decoder is because the
encoders are imagenet networks that are
designed to classify an image by saying
that image is people right I don't care
about the different people it's like
that image is whole people so you want
to collapse all the pixels all on you
right to a single class so we said hey
well instead of like taking those
networks that exist at our design for
image classification that degrades
special information a lot and then
trying very hard to elucidate the
details back let's just not degrade that
information let's just not destroy it in
the first place and so here instead of
max pooling right we do packing and so
packing is the same thing as for
compression right image compression you
you you can imagine that here what we
want is instead of like decimating the
signal we're learning to compress we're
learning a transformation that says here
are the the noise remove that part I
consider this as noise and really
preserve the information content that I
need for my photometric loss right and
so here what we do is we learn blocks
and I'll show you a little bit of
intuition that learn to compress right
learn to do a lossy compression of the
signal as input and then same thing the
no absenting we learn to unpack to
basically decompress so it's like
basically learning a codec and
so here's the packing and unpacking
blocks a little bit of technical details
so this is what people typically do
right it's like when you do max pulling
and you do up sampling you're basically
just like turning a Gaussian into a
pixel and you're turning a pixel into a
Gaussian right that's that's what you're
doing you're blurring things out right
or decimating here instead what we do is
we take the whole signal and then we do
this like interesting aspect that's like
intuition that came from super
resolution which is when you have
tensors like in this shape right be CHW
right so B is the batch size so let's
say you just have one image these one C
is the number of channels right so when
it's the color image it's three channels
but further down it's your size of your
representation your intermediate
representations H is the height width is
their width in pixels so one of the
things you can see is you can say well
if you see few G's as a tensor you can
actually reshape the underlying tensor
to structure the pixels in different
ways and and reinterpret basically that
tensors dimensions so here this is what
space to def does it's a very simple
operation that basically just says hey
what if I want to reduce my resolution H
and W by a factor of two right along
each dimension so H divided by two w but
what do I do with the rest of the
remaining pixels right like so max
pooling would just say throw them out
right here we say well actually just
pack them into the channels so you're
taking basically a 2 by 2 region and
instead of replacing it with the max
value you're saying let's replace this 2
by 2 region by a 4 dimensional vector
right that's it that's really just it so
for those of you that know new pipe I
torture it's a reshape that's that's
everything you're doing right and so
then what yours but what you have is now
you said I traded spatial details and I
reinterpreted the spatial details as
features and now I can learn to compress
that feature space into a lower
dimensional feature space and so we're
doing an expansion and contraction there
because we are that feature space is
probably not a very good feature space
for convolutions because convolutions
our translation invariance you're taking
special details backing them along the
channel so yes so you're just
- interpreting them so it might not be
very easily learn about so we expand
them into a higher dimensional feature
space where convolutions make more sense
so that's why we use a 3d convolution
and then we pack them right so we do an
expansion kit so reshape expansion
contraction a little bit technical but
the end effects that it has is it
basically expands vastly the receptive
field right which is a key problem in
computer vision is like like convolution
theoretic convolutions they make a
decision based on the 3x3 pixel region
and so you have to stack a lot of those
if you want to reason across the scene
to say like oh that's a road pixel
that's the road pixel yeah I know
because they're close right so here
you're basically have some kind of like
a tiling effect that happens in that
network which enables you to say I don't
care that all these pixels are really
really close to each other like putting
the exactly the same weight on things
that are very very close it's like
redundant right it's like a waste of
energy or waste of parameters and so
here it's basically doing some kind of
tiling basically this is like learned
right to say hey if I want to see
further I need to trade off some of the
like redundant things to basically pay
less attention to things that are
redundant and so that I can spread my
attention a little bit further with the
same number of parameters right
unpacking is similar but in the reverse
operation the velocity scaling that I
mentioned before this is just to show
you some results that I think it's
pretty cool you have a face transition I
love face transition so that compressed
sensing you know like so Stanford has
like you know done one of the papers
that I like the most about you know math
closes math - magic which is about
compressed sensing and so I look for
phase transitions and things and and
here one thing that was super cool is
this velocity Supervision right that
says we constrain the magnitude of our
ego motion estimator you see that
basically like it takes awhile to learn
the scale intrinsic scale and then very
quickly it catches up onto the intrinsic
scale so this is just like to show you
some evidence that you don't need to
know scale of the scene that test time
you can learn it through the network and
it basically just latches on to that
global optimum during training okay we
beat the state-of-the-art and I'm not
going to go through all these numbers
it's just like a big wall of numbers to
scare you to show you that it takes a
lot of efforts to
show that it works but you have to do
this when you're a scientist
you can't just claim we're the best look
at our stuff awesome
ship it you need to actually do these
duties these experiments that take a lot
of time and effort one of the things
that's super cool though is the numbers
that I highlighted it's not just that we
we got the best results in terms of self
supervised learning by improving a lot
so this is like apps rel is that so
there's many metrics this basically tell
you where is the absolute relative error
you make with respect to lidar right in
terms of like distance and one thing
that's very interesting is that for the
first time and I have made that claim to
try to see if people would disprove me
so far nobody has disproved me even
myself trying to find in the literature
but this is the first time that I'm
aware of where self supervised learning
actually works better than supervised
learning these methods are supervised
methods where what they do is instead of
paying this photometric loss you know
using geometry as a source of
supervision what they do is they say
well let's just learn from sequences
where I have recorded image and lidar at
the same time I know the extrinsic
calibration so I can project a point
cloud onto the image I have not too much
parallax and therefore I can formulate
this as a regression problem that's how
things started by the way beyond the
cone excetera I was like pixel as input
regress the depth target def given to me
by lidar these are the state-of-the-art
methods for supervised learning and now
are you telling you a little bit but
still we are better than supervised
methods so I'm super excited about this
because this is on kitty kitty is
standard benchmark and autumn is driving
in the research community it's
ridiculously small its tiny that Network
is very big and so here you would say
well tiny data very big Network
you are so overfitting we have actually
done experiments where we showed that
this network actually generalized better
than any other network on on other data
and so here how's that possible right
and the reason is because again we
capture a better prior right we have
more structure baked into our network
and
our loss and that's how with more
parameters we can learn better and
generalize better so these are some
results that show this so this is like
basically train on tea tea and then we
extend it to new scenes right so yeah
sorry at the end cool
so one of the things here is you can't
call it a pseudo lidar Network if it's
not deployable as the lidar right a
lidar sensor in clear good conditions
you put it on a car in Singapore you put
in a car in Tokyo you put in a car in
u.s. it will give you that you're not
gonna say oh no I don't trust the Tokyo
version of the lidar no no you know it's
it's a sensor it's an active sensor so
our system is learned it's not an active
sensor it's a passive sensor that's
hallucinating the depth from how things
look by capturing it from some data so
generalization performance is a key
aspect of being able to make any claim
about the usefulness of pseudo lidar and
so here what we show is that if you take
existing architectures which are generic
architectures resonates that are
designed for image classification that
were like state of the art and are that
we improved upon but they were really
good they generalize way worse to a new
environment so new scenes as a new data
set is made by the Newton amigas which
is I think Boston and Singapore so
nothing to do with Karlsruhe Germany
which is kidney right and so and so
really that was very encouraging and
again reinforces that if you have a good
prior if you have a good structure in
your model in your learning you will
generalize better and we have more
parameters so we have more parameters
than these networks and yet we
generalize better although we're trying
on small data and we improve with data
the other thing is self supervised
learning the whole point of software
learning is not to Train on kitty is
that what if I have this again 10
petabytes of data can I train on that
and is it better than if I have one
petabyte of data is it better than if I
have 100 gigabytes of data and so you
want networks that scale with data
because they can scale with the labeling
but maybe they don't scare on
performance so we show that we do scale
with data which again as for point
clouds has for how self supervised
methods scale with data very few papers
show that
yet that's a whole motivation
qualitative results you can look at the
paper we're better on fine fine
structures where again this is our
network better than the best self
supervised better than the bests
semi-supervised are fully supervised
right lidar you don't have light our
points in the cloud so that in the in
the sky so you have some issues with
that right so that's also one reason
this is like last year's cvpr two years
no two year cvpr
so just for your information like that
that versus that the pace of the field
is crazy and you would think it's data a
compute except no no it's kitty this is
all the same so it's all about the
architecture it's all about the
architecture it's all about the loss so
it's about the algorithm one thing that
super cool is is you can look at crazy
things like again like cones you know
you have like when you do it time is
driving and you work in the Bay Area and
there's construction all the freakin
time
you have to model cones like I hate
cones like it's not you know especially
with like fancy lidar sensors that work
at like 250 meter range that can pulse
really really nicely and then you have
this retro fact rich retro reflective
surfaces on cone right next to you that
crazy explosion so here we like it's
it's we learned from we learned from raw
data you see cones you know you use our
static objects you moved around them you
captured the 3d structure you can relate
how a cone looks like to how a cone is
in 3d space other cool things is science
sharp boundaries posed right so things
that are very thin structures if you do
it at a reduced resolution if you do it
like 5 or 10 32 by 32 resolution you
can't learn these things so operating at
a very high resolution preserving fine
details enable you to capture things
thin structures like poles you don't
want to collide with a pole it's thin
sure but you don't want to collide with
a pole even thinner fences this is my
favorite when I saw this I said I don't
care it just goes into the paper this
figure it goes into the paper you can
see and you can look at the paper it's
in the paper fences we can
it's like that there's a fence and we
can detect the thin like part structures
of the fence and and projects the right
depth behind the fence so that is really
like an example of how what you can gain
from like high resolution okay so we can
learn from all the data it gets better
with the data just from video that's
cool
does it get better I highlighted that
yes it gets it gets better and it
depends so there's still research to be
done so we had a paper at a nice email
workshop on self service learning where
we're showing that we said okay now
let's Kiki that's great let's try to use
1 million of frames from our logs right
just 1 million like the image net size
roughly and see if that improves the
results the answer is yes
however one thing that's interesting is
I'll just summarize this for you is
obvious is that cityscapes which is not
data set which is also in Germany right
so very close to TT and is manually
curated it's 80 thousand images it's
better than 1 million images from random
in random Toyota images from the US and
so it's not just about quantity of data
it's also about quality of data
relevance and that here is we don't know
how to measure distributions in that
space and there's a huge space of pixels
and and and so it's still a very open
question of what data that it's not just
the quantity is what data what diversity
what quality what relevance to select
and an active learning doesn't work here
because you are in an unsupervised
setting so it improves your pose
estimation to again as I said in a
structure promotion setup you need both
the depth and a go motion Network and
they are trained together and so but
then then you know so far I showed like
and oppose network is thrown out well
you know visual odometry is somewhat
important in robotics and so here we
actually went further and say ok if
we're just focusing on visual odometry
at this time how good is it
and so we are presenting at coral an
aural paper
in Osaka in a few weeks now which is
called two stream networks for self
supervising emotion estimation where we
tried to bring like focus that sets this
time to network architecture design for
the pose Network so this thing here
right so I'll go quickly over this but
we trained them together my localization
odometry I don't think to that audience
I need to justify that it's important
and and and especially how to improve
otama tree with a visual imagery of data
so that's the network architecture again
I told you before the main thing the
main source of improvement before was
was designing a network and a loss that
factors in structural assumption you
know that whole to be true because
geometry right and so here we have a two
stream network which is typically used
in action recognition where you have an
appearance stream and a motion stream so
for instance you use RGB and optical
flow and combine them together here
we're basically just saying well
actually if you know the structure of
the scene and and you can basically do a
geometric registration right like you
can localize you know that's why lidar
czar so much more accurate for
localization so let's make a two stream
network that has a structure stream that
takes the depth as input and the Piron
stream and and then combine them to get
a better estimate of the pose so that
works that that improves again numbers
papers online you can check it out and
we can talk at coral if you're there now
start from the crazy kind of like
research he wealth and like literally
going down into you know like getting
the hands dirty and and making this
deployable because again the goal is to
actually have an impact it positive
impact on the world with this and so in
the real world it's still too far from
being deployable this technology and so
how do we accelerate its deployment and
so as I mentioned before we do have
lidar sometimes you know like either
like a very fancy lidar when you when
you have a research fleet of prototype
l4 fleet or in certain cars in the
future you have these four beam light
ours so what if we do have some light
our points
sometimes can we leverage that and
that's and that's recent work again that
we're presenting as an overall at coral
robust semi-supervised monocular deaf
estimation we've rejected distances so
we'd love to be yourself supervised
purist and just learn from raw data but
in the real world if you care about
actually making this you know getting to
these nine nines of reliability
some I supervise is obviously the way to
go from a research standpoint you know
you we have a lot of data that's and
labeled some data that is labeled the
hard part is how what you do with the
unlabeled data so that's why we focus on
self supervise but in the real world we
have obviously some amount of
supervision so how do we leverage both
in an optimal way I'll I'll skip this
because in the interest of time and if
we won't have time for questions at the
end but one thing that that basically
just says is supervision from let's say
regression regressing light art right
our points and self supervision which is
a loss paid on pixel on color values
right the photometric loss there are
very different losses so when you do
multitask learning and you just say oh
let's I have a loss that compares
bananas and I have a loss that compares
sheeps let's sum those losses well it
doesn't work so well in practice
so we have to somehow make these two
losses compatible and and so here what
we're doing is there is this additional
like piece here I can grab a pointer the
supervised loss right so like supervised
networks it just don't need all the rest
rights they just need like get me the
depth and I have the ground truth depth
DT just how close are you from that
right so what we're doing is what we
found we tried a lot of different things
because we started obviously we're not
Eve and we said all right cool
I get state-of-the-art supervised
Network state-of-the-art self supervised
Network have make them have babies and
these babies will be beautiful
the first baby was not beautiful I can
tell you so then we Sarah gay why and so
we came up with this approach worked the
best which is self supervised
pre-training
so one of the other thing is that again
you have a lot of data that's unlabeled
you have some data that's labeled one
traditional way to do it is like to some
pre training on the unlabeled data and a
little bit of fine-tuning on the labeled
data so this is basically what we've
done with the little difference that we
maintain also the self supervise laughs
in the second stage so you do self
supervise pre-training then you do
fine-tuning with the supervised loss
plus a reproject sort so a reprojected
supervised loss and the self supervised
loss this reprojected loss is important
and this is basically the illustration
of the rejected loss which is the main
contribution in the paper which is when
you're doing this supervised loss you're
comparing distances between 3d points in
Euclidean space right this is very
different than the view synthesis which
is comparing other 3d points but these
are RGB values right so this is
completely different so one of the
things we found is is that we're
basically reprojected the 3d distances
onto a distance between pixels and then
we're novel izing these two losses such
that it's better behaved numerically
it's like mostly numerical optimization
considerations that enable this to to be
better behaved at training time one of
the benefits by the way of using the
supervision that I haven't mentioned is
that you capture scale metric scale in
your network much faster right so it
works great actually I'll show you the
video and one of the cool things that we
investigated is so here what you're
seeing is you're seeing the image you're
seeing the points out so this is the
point cloud so if for those of you that
are familiar with the Qt they use a
valid ein VLP HDL 64 which is 64 beam
lidar and and they accumulate the scans
over a little bit of time to densify the
point cloud right and so you're seeing
these the height map the point clouds
that are red and green etc these are
from the lidar and let me pause this
just a little bit right and so what we
are doing is we're doing our monocular
def network takes a single image at the
time
and then lifts the pixels to 3d right
and there you sing again this dance
reconstruction that I was showing before
and we're just shot superimposing with
the lidar to see that how close are we
to the lidar remember our network is
metrically scaled this is metrically
scaled so this is accurate like if this
like you could drive off of this don't
but you could don't and so here what
you're going to see is what is the
supervision you leverage so the
supervision you leverage could be the
full point cloud right so if you're
fully supervised you have the full point
cloud you say every pixel that sig
matches that can be ray casted close
enough to alight our points I'm gonna
use that supervision and now one thing
is what if you have instead of sixty
four beams what if you have thirty two
beams right we can decimate right what
if you go for the cheaper Villa dining
model you'll be 32 see for instance
right or you know even maybe what if you
had 16 beams like the VIP 16 which I'm
pretty sure robotics folks at Stanford
have been using and all the way down to
four beams which is the Continental type
like like for being lidar excedrin and
so what we found in the paper is that
when you train with supervision that's
degraded in a number of beams you train
with 64 beams or turn to 32 or trained
with 16 or trained with 8 or training
with four our models accuracy is like
degrading very slowly which means it's
very robust to the decimating the lidar
or using a very cheap lighter and the
last point I will make is one additional
work we've done is obviously to drive in
the world to have a robot that can
interact with the world it's not just
about 3d right it's not just about
understanding geometry it's about also
the semantics so we do also a lot of
work on semantic segmentation and object
detection and all these kind of things
and obviously there's a relationship
between semantics and and geometry and
otherwise our monocular definite works
they would not work
right imagine you take a picture of the
scene and you say you can tell how far
things are the only reason I can tell
like how far you are is because faces
right have an equivalence relationship
between their appearance and their
distance right a smaller face like you
have big faces and small faces in the
world right there's all kinds of faces
but you don't have a 2-meter face and a
2-centimeter face right so you can tell
from experience from not having seen all
your faces before I can tell how far you
are even if I take a photograph and I
was looking at the photograph right
that's why I'm monocular def works so
there's obviously a relationship between
semantics and def otherwise it couldn't
work so how about we leverage that
semantic relationship a little bit more
explicitly now the caveat is and so we
have a paper under review for this not
yet an archive but will soon be
semantically guided representation
learning for self super eyes monocular
depth and at a high level this is how it
works
semantics has to be supervised right
because the reason I see two eyes in
these kind of things is because people
call this a face right like I could call
it their smirk you know you all have
smirks now that doesn't matter I mean in
my labeling system it's like ID 77 it's
whatever so we don't want any labeling
right you want to stay in the self
supervised setting so let's assume you
have a semantic segmentation at work
that's pre trained on some other data
set right it's there so you have it as
part of your system but you don't have
on the big unlabeled data set you don't
have semantic supervision so you fix
that Network you learn yourself
supervised deaf Network in the same way
I described before but with one
additional thing one additional
structure you're going to input into
your system you're going to say well
actually for deaf to be accurate you
have to have depth features that
correlate with semantic features right
because again like the size of this
chair and the size of your faces have
nothing to do with each other but if I
see many chairs and many faces and I
know that there are chairs and faces I
can relate their distance with their
appearance so we use a very recent paper
actually called pixel adaptive
convolutions to basically use features
that are extracted in a semantic
limitation network to guide the learning
to say your geometry features right your
representations that you're going to
learn they have to
have some relationship right with
semantic features and we learned that
relationship right and it's basically an
additional guidance or regularizer
this works better well of numbers boom
done but one thing is like we're right
where does it work better right so to
give you the intuition I highlighted a
couple of examples and basically you see
without semantic guidance on the left so
in the middle column with semantic
guidance on the right so here what you
see for instance is here you have this
tree which is very hard to see right you
see you're like high dynamic high
dynamic range big problem right and
outdoors and here you see you have this
black tree and you have this shadow and
you have this shaded building and so
here really hard to like from just
photometric perspective right to tell
that that part of the pole is actually
not part of the building but it's a pole
it's not a building and so here having
the semantic guidance enables you to
recover the accurate depth on this
another thing same same exact problem
with the sign the traffic sign same
thing here here no sign no speed limit
go for it here there's this little thing
over there here very interesting case
same thing kind of like almost like an
imaging problem like a dynamic range
problem it's like oh here
there's no pedestrian that's just coming
across you you know right here no no
you're fine here well just wait a second
right and again this is because there
are semantic features that are like
basically designed to be learned to be
invariance to a lot of photometric
aspects whereas the depth needs like I
need these photometric aspects because
that's how I tell the geometric
relationships right the matching right
same thing for like rare categories and
and and many other instances of very
fine grain structures this improves
overall classes and once you do this you
can basically start to do 3d semantics
and and combine those and so basically
this is just showing the pre-trained
network the learned network for depth
the point cloud you get from so the
point cloud you get from this and what
if you just in paints the point cloud
with the semantics right and you start
to be able to have cameras let's start
to
look like a really good sensor for full
3d semantic understanding in the world
we have an additional last stage that I
will mention like infinite depth and
that's my last slide where basically one
of the cool things geometry wise like
from a mathematical perspective like
take home exercise think about it is
when you reproject right and you have a
dynamic object that moves at exactly the
same speed as you move right so my hand
here like always the same distance from
my eyes right now there's two ways that
you can reproject this accurately from a
photometric standpoint it's like the
hand is moving at the same speed as I'm
moving or my hand is infinitely big at
infinity all right
it never gets closer right things that
never get closer means that they must be
at infinity if they're infinity they
must be infinitely big because they just
occupied that much space from a
projective geometry standpoint this is a
valid solution right this is an
ambiguous solution to your photometric
objective so what we see is we see these
cars that have like you know violate
relativity and just can warp into
infinite space and so that car that you
see here or here they are at infinite
distance because they travel you know
when you're in the road when you follow
a lead vehicle you're typically not like
you know unless you're a bad driver
but you're typically going at the same
speed so with we proposed in the paper
also a two-stage training method which
is completely automatic unlabeled and
we're basically suddenly seeing like oh
that car that you thought was a Definity
it's actually just right in front of
your nose right so to conclude we've
done a lot of work on self supervised
pseudo lidar or monocular depth at gri
the real reason is we want robust 3d
perception from vision robustness is a
key world when you hear people say
perception is solved you can ask them
sure is robust perception solved right
that's really robustness is key and when
you have a robot that costs several
million dollars robustness is even more
key and when you have human lives and
you deploy in 10 million you get the
picture so use geometry for scalable
soft supervision that's basically kind
of like the key message structure
structure structure if you've been that
I clear the top deep learning Khan
friends before it was unsupervised no
structure and now everybody is saying
how do I put structure in my deep nets
right so geometry is is really the key
we talked about stereo they have a super
dev and PAC net semi-supervised also
again if you combine losses make sure
you're not comparing bananas and and and
sheep's and one cool quote I think is
really nice it comes from a really
interesting professor in in in computer
vision of you're shy process the
revolution will not be supervised so
when you think about robots it's kind of
scary right is that like robots are not
supervised is you know like my adviser
gave me this robot it's gonna crash and
like falls through the stairs and oh my
god and and and when you think about
deploying into a real world system like
you can imagine how we freaked out on a
daily basis and so you have to really be
bold in but safe at the same time and so
I think that's what really we're trying
to do and and really the key here is
they're not magic right it's science
it's actually a lot of geometry I bought
again the old zisserman geometry book
right like go back I went back to my
roots
because it's a structure that you want
to leverage and in the real world the
data is also mostly unlabeled right it's
not unlabeled it's not labeled is mostly
unlabeled and that's the key thing all
right thank you
[Applause]
now we'll take a few questions
all right do you had waited for a long
time yes big table had self some the
point I was curious about was so you had
three buildings down there at the bottom
and so you also helps yep and I see here
that your resolution is about twice the
dorm one you're hearing too so that's
one thing and then the other thing that
I was what is the I guess CS plus key
means you're also using say escapes you
trained on yeah okay really good
attention to details so a couple of
things first in the paper we compared to
with the Monod f2 which is the state of
the art self supervised network which is
amazing work like really really cool
they they improvements from their method
which actually you can see here they do
not improve with resolution so their
network works just as well with half the
resolution so that's another key thing
and so what we have in the paper we show
is that if you increase the resolution
of the method saturate they can't deal
with the details they're designed to
work at lower resolution so if they
become really good they're become at
what we call medium resolution that high
resolution doesn't bring them a benefit
we get as good on medium resolution and
then we improve with higher resolution
and then when you're supervise your
resolution is limited to your lidar
right so you can't go beyond what your
lidar provides in terms of resolution so
that's also an interesting limitation so
yes it's an unfair advantage to be able
to really leverage high resolution and
that's by design of this work absolutely
yeah and CS plus K we do there's all
kinds of little bit of analysis that I
brushed over you can look at in the
paper any other question
yes I think you were first and you then
one great question in regards to the
cameras because em I don't think you've
passed the prior of the intrinsics of
the cameras anywhere and so you would
have to retrain the whole network and
yes we are assuming we know the interim
six we are assuming that all our data is
with the same camera that's a very very
very big assumption there is really that
was an assumption that's necessary to
get some good results at this stage now
that we get good results we're actually
thinking about how to go beyond that and
one way is to is to learn a
differentiable camera model where you
actually have insurance ticks that are
differentiable so you can learn to
predict intrinsics and there's some work
that are like I think I need a needle
galava at Google was looking into being
like you know really agnostic to
extrinsic but in real world deployments
that scale you know the intrinsic so you
have a pretty darn good calibration but
it's nonetheless an interesting like you
know if you think Android versus iOS iOS
you have really good calibration Android
is like well you're on the answer so we
had this and right so to kind of go back
to your last point on why and robustness
so it seems like from what I could tell
most of these images that you're
training on are like in full sunlight
perfect weather conditions go how does
it how have you tested it against like
you know night against bringing or lots
of reductions or super HD are related
images pressure is building up for the
next questions you got to be all smarter
like you know increments so yes we are
not testing for night that's outside of
our safety domain right now so lidar
obviously has benefits near infrared
cameras etc so visual light if you have
no light but one of the things we have
tested in is rain so rain that's one of
the big pushes that actually convinces
people to say let's try to make like
let's do research on the vision to
really like we need it is this rain
so I mentioned luminaire sensor right
1550 nanometer range the reason that it
has better like range and depth
perception is because at the 15 15
nanometer range you are absorbing the
the laser pulse faster which is more I
say fat higher pulsing levels but if it
gets absorbed by water better then under
the rain you have you know this big
problems and also in the more practical
design of the robot you know like we
have to tilt the lens so that you know
or have ultrasonic sand and so that you
don't have raindrops because if you have
raindrops have a big blind spot etc so
vision like raindrops is noise why they
you can still see it's just added some
noise so what we found is that these
methods are very robust to rain because
if you train with rain if you collect
rain data so here doesn't happen too
much but we have an office in Ann Arbor
we do have rain data and Tokyo so one of
the big things actually that t-shirt is
next year we're doing a big demo at the
Tokyo Olympics so Toyota is number one
sponsor and we're gonna have a fleet of
cars that have continues operations for
like 30 days and it's typhoon season
like so the good thing about it is it
doubled the motivation to get vision to
be really good fog
etc so lidar also has very similar
problems than this but vision because it
can be as good as your data has fails
later so you should be able to between
close points of time estimate really
well what the relative changes in pose
right so I'm curious if you've
considered like a multi frame
architecture where you're looking across
multiple frames but you're also feeding
in the relative pose change yeah yeah
again continuing on they're really good
questions yes absolutely yes so the real
world is sensor fusion right the robotic
to get robustness you know as a
Byzantine generals problem you need
redundancy there's no way around it so
you need multiple sensors you need
multiple systems so you need to fuse
them together and now there's
interesting new ways to choose things
right when it's a sensor fusion you
think Talman filter so actually my boss
is wolfenberg yard right so Bible of
robotics Provost Icke robotics and and
so obviously there's all that literature
right but that will merge with a new
emerging literature which is around deep
learning so residual networks right so
what if you have a really good
initialization for your pose and you
just learned a residual from it it's
like almost like learning a noise model
oh like oh now you've made the
connection with Kalman filters etc and
now people are saying oh actually I can
back up through the Kalman equations oh
actually I can back prop even through my
particle filter so there's really this
kind of like just like geometry and deep
learning like kind of like merging
together we're gonna see the same
probabilistic robotics and deep learning
starting to merge together and it's like
new ways to do sensor fusion in a
data-driven way that's yeah so that's
I'm very excited for that space but it's
still like there's a lot of research to
be done if you hear also people that
says it's all an engineering problem
it's all an execution problem then you
know they're working for a different
thing they're working on something that
is a robo taxi in an area that in a
fully HD map and I can always HTML
that's that's one problem if you're
looking for a robot with autonomous in
the open world
you need to think about those things
really like and then do research on yes
yep again you pass the quality of
question tests are good yes this is a
very good question
Universal representation versus mixture
of experts that's like do you want to
took your model do you want so for
instance what I think we did very
recently I can tell you about this
traffic lights so traffic lights is an
area where you can't fail right like
some Robo taxi company not like some
company that's doing taxi that wants to
become Robo taxi first deployment to San
Francisco within the hour burn a red
light
right you've all seen the YouTube video
it's it's so it's really hard like you
want to be like it in their defense it's
really hard you have to be really really
really robust so now really robots in
the u.s. awesome go to Tokyo wait all
the traffic lights are like this
wait traffic lights are like two rows
wait traffic lights have states that are
conflicting according to the US traffic
lights so you can have something that
tells you literally you can go no wait
you can and you're like wait what like
and so really and so and then you're
like oh let's use structure and let's
use a state machine and oh we can
actually learn that state machine and oh
let's learn transitions etc you go to
Tokyo you take that garbage can right so
so how much do you specialize versus how
much do you say III tabula rasa I assume
nothing I would just learn it from data
which is gonna make you very slow and
and very risky very active research and
again it has to be on a case-by-case
basis but one thing that's I believe on
the general note on this is that
representation learning right a car is a
car certain things are looked the same
or are the same certain behaviors are
shared because we're all humans right
and and gravity is there and you know
all these kind of things so there is a
common bottleneck there's a really cool
paper by Stefano so a toll on a
separation principle for control and the
age of deep learning which is like on
the information theoretic side of things
which which is this notion of
information bottleneck and you want to
have a state that is a summary state of
what is common across the world for your
particular task and then you want to
have a specialization right everybody is
doing multitask learning right so like a
provision you see as a common backbone
and multiple heads the key question is
what is shareable what is a good state
that is shareable and then depending on
that if you share a lot you can have a
single multitask model if you share very
little you can have separate models and
in between you can have some form of
mixture of experts that can be geo local
AG or localized or you can switch which
branch you're going through and you kept
the conditional architecture says like
oh here take the Tokyo branch eccentric
strong so this is this is
open and on the case-by-case basis the
very hard question
[Applause]